start our live stream
stream live on youtube and linkedin
and
the process takes about 30 seconds
so
okay good
all right
welcome to our worldwide audience uh
to our career master class
we're going to pre previewing um
the trends in cloud computing and devops
coming up for 2022
i'm with matthew david a digital leader
accenture and one of our
esteemed experts
at simply learn
my name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here
and my role is to
sit in the background to facilitate i
would like to give you a couple of tips
on using the controls for webex
please use the q a button
to ask a question for matthew and please
feel free to put your questions in the q
a at any time they
they come to mind we will cue them up
for the q a portion of the webinar
at the end of his presentation and
you can chat with the host and presenter
it will give you the all panelists
option
if you want to get a message to us
but please again put your questions in q
a
and we will also be doing a couple of
polls today at the beginning and end of
the session
and the first one here
is about you
we're curious to know
what your current job role is
and we're also
checking in with everyone during this
pandemic about
how they're feeling
and how they're holding up with all the
confusion
lockdowns and new variants and things
like that
so you have about 10 seconds more for
the pull
okay and here are the results
so the biggest uh
proportion of our audience is our
students
we it's fairly distributed among the
other job roles
um
the job role of other is the second
largest contingent
and it's good to see that
almost all of you are doing well or
doing at least okay
and we hope that
sharing this information
will
help the rest of you feel a bit better
about
how 2022 will turn out for you
so with that i'm going to introduce
matt
matthew david is a digital leader
accenture
um he's a leader in cloud
devops ai and blockchain
and he is a published author of 13 books
and so we're very pleased and fortunate
to have him here today and thank you
very much matt
i'm going to turn the floor over to you
stupid thank you very much for inviting
me it's always a pleasure to be working
with you i'm just going to go ahead and
share my screen uh hopefully that will
come up in a moment
and let me know if you can see my screen
okay so so first i want to congratulate
everybody for being here today um one of
the reasons why we have cloud and devops
uh in the same title is that it is very
difficult to talk about um
the the technology of cloud and the
practice of devops without referring to
both of them together um one of the the
changes that i have seen in my career is
just the explosion of capabilities that
you can accomplish through the cloud
but to be able to get to those
capabilities has just been
a steady and continuous maturing of the
skill set which is devops
to be able to deliver those solutions
and so as we look at cloud we look at
devops really the two are very very much
uh
hand in hand
um the the second point i want to
congratulate you on is that you are
probably in the most fierce market uh
for talent and uh every year um i talk
about uh the the talent demand uh for
leading technologies and cloud and
devops are in that category
and
and every year it just continues to
increase
interestingly though in 2020 we have
seen a
a pivot in demand i mean we've seen it
globally
where the number of uh jobs um is
significantly sc available the
availability for those jobs is
significantly scaling up
way beyond the ability for people to
fill those roles and this is for all
jobs across all uh opportunities um and
none more so
than we're seeing with cloud and devops
and then the reason why
we're seeing just such an explosion of
the demand for
roles within cloud and devops
is directly related to uh automation of
systems to being able to scale to
customer demands as people spend more
time
working from home myself personally
i work for a consulting company and
traditionally we travel a lot
i haven't traveled for two years my
entire career for the last two years has
been working from home uh which i'm
quite happy with actually at the moment
um but we see this um those uh just
across all industries just the kind of
the the demand for digital technologies
has really escalated forward really a
whole decade um and so the skill sets
you um are looking to acquire or have
acquired uh in this space um just really
tremendous
so i kind of want to talk about um
the rapid growth of
cloud providers as we kick things off
and and you'll hear me talk about uh
really what we call the big three which
is uh amazon web service aws
microsoft azure and google cloud
platform or gcp
um
but here's the reality is that in the
last uh
really the last two or three years the
growth
of cloud providers has gone
significantly beyond just the the big
three uh oracle is now a significant
cloud provider uh
driving um significant revenue um
certainly
when i look at
working with our cloud partners and
working with our clients
two years ago i wouldn't have considered
oracle today oracle accounts for about
five to ten percent of my business so
very important um that you you look at
what oracle is doing um but outside of
oracle we have uh work that's been done
with um alibaba alibaba has a phenomenal
suite of uh tool sets um that you can
leverage
and then you have 10 cent huawei uh just
a lot of um
opportunity for growing uh cloud
expertise so if we look and just kind of
um that some of the growth patterns and
and this week's an interesting week
because we have ignite from aws um is
happening uh right now and some very
interesting announcements coming out and
we'll we'll talk about those in a little
bit um but if we look at just some of
the growth um the the from just the top
three providers in um and the figures i
have here are from 2020 they don't
include uh 2021 figures but we just see
a significant
growth and we're talking about 29
uh year-over-year growth i mean it's
just phenomenal um there are very few
industries that have that type of growth
at that scale i mean when you're looking
at um 29
growth but in the billions um that's
tremendous growth
and we see it across um
all of the major platforms it's not just
specific to aws or azure it's across all
the platforms um and uh the one that's
really of interest is google they've
seen 50 plus growth um i would say that
they are still
for as large as google is they are still
in the um
rapid growth phase and i see that
continuing uh for at least the next
couple of years
um and
again um
it's just a tremendous growth in these
spaces and now what's interesting though
is that um uh the the pivot really uh
the companies are going from is i think
over the last five years every company
has
stepped into cloud in one way or another
but the pivot is
not just on uh data storage and compute
power which is really often the first
step that people take when they move
into a cloud but the pivot is going into
how do you use cloud native and how do
you go ahead and start building out
solutions that are built on top of cloud
and this is where your skills as devops
engineers really come into play because
we're looking at uh taking
services that are available within the
cloud environment being able to string
them together um effectively
but then also being able to incorporate
uh systems that uh companies are already
running i mean so this is the challenges
uh most of the companies going to the
cloud
they already have been around for
5 10
20 30 even more years and have large
complex systems uh crm systems um uh
supply chain management systems i mean
just these very large systems and what
they're looking at is how do we take
advantage of the cloud and the speed and
acceleration that you can have in the
cloud and then bring in our own systems
and this is where um having skill sets
around api development event driven
architecture micro macro services all
skills that require uh
devops teams
and particularly um as we now move into
dev dev secops um
in creation of those
services
um and so let me just kind of skip on to
the next screen here so so what kind of
the services you know can cloud
providers uh offer um so i've broken
down uh this slide into like kind of
three key areas uh we have
infrastructure as a service platform of
service and uh solution as a service um
and then from that you have a kind of a
breakdown
of all the different services that are
available from virtual networking of
shared file storage
uh
data services
uh deployment services and and typically
as you look at
the structure for many of the cloud
providers out there this is how they
break things down so let me just kind of
fill this in a little bit and so here we
have what it looks like for an aws
infrastructure
and i'd be very intrigued to know
how many of these services that you've
used
one of the things that is
very interesting is that as you look at
the companies the cloud providers out
there
and the increasing number of services
that they provide
something you have to remember is that
all those services can be tightly
interconnected with each other um and so
this is where you would write functions
in the cloud to be able to connect those
systems and services together to be able
to really accelerate your delivery
interestingly enough when
aws and azure when they when those as as
companies when they launched they really
only launched with one or two services
and aws today has over 1800 services um
and if you bear in mind how complex the
environment now becomes you now have to
start thinking about becoming
specialized within areas within
aws or within azure um because keeping
up with just all of the services is
almost impossible
consider this with 1800 services uh all
those services even if they only get uh
one update um a year which they're not
they're all getting multiple updates
they're getting extended with new
functionality on a
regular basis plus new services are
being introduced
uh you're still looking at
a dozen or so changes every single day
to all the services across the platform
and so i'm just going to kind of skip
through that the next couple slides here
but just you know this is a breakdown of
what we see from an aws environment um
something very similar with microsoft
azure i actually need to do some updates
to the slide um because we have a couple
of missing
buckets that
microsoft has over the last year
filled out
my personal preference is working in the
azure environment and and this just
comes from a bias of i've been working
with
microsoft for a very long time um aws is
is very good all the platforms are very
good um
but this is just the area that i
personally enjoy working in
um and and again this is a focus on
public cloud and it's interesting that i
just saw that question come and um one
of the things that we have to also then
be looking at into the future um and
we'll be talking a little bit about this
is kind of the evolution of what i see
as the post cloud transformation so
public cloud has really done a lot for
us um one of the things that you'll
start not seeing more and more um and
were announced um just at ignite this
week is just the uh the importance of
moving the cloud closer and closer to
the enterprise so having
more important and behind all of this
within your devops environment is
security and just being able to maintain
and manage that security environment
um so that was just an overview of the
the services they are continuing to
evolve and grow over um the next year um
i don't see um any of this shrinking at
all
um and so
the uh the next session and second
question i have is you know what are
some of the benefits of leveraging cloud
native solutions and and i really think
that cloud native is going to
uh
significantly accelerate over the next
year and hopefully some of you are
already uh learning a cloud native
solutions so
um on this slide is an example of a
solution that one of my teams um put
together uh on the the right hand side
we have a
a modern approach to building out the
solution uh but not using uh cloud
native services um and so
you'll see a lot of the tools that
are you know still considered modern we
have uh hadoop flume spark uh cassandra
as you know some of the tool sets that
we're using uh everything is written on
a linux platform uh open source stack uh
you know in itself very modern um it's
not using uh kind of the the traditional
um model that you would see with a more
more older legacy system
um but interestingly enough
um the the amount of time um and the
amount of compute that we have for that
um the actual time to build out that
solution uh was was quite some time with
several weeks to put build that together
i think it was ended up being like three
or four months to build out a core
solution now if you pivot over to the
left hand side where we have everything
native and what we did is we actually
had a small team and so we went from a
team of
about 12 people and and we actually had
one team that said look i we feel
strongly that we can actually duplicate
what we've built even without our you
know modern tools we feel that we can
actually duplicate that leveraging all
of the services that might that um aws
has to offer um and again this is just
um getting a strong understanding of all
the services that aws have which is just
phenomenal um and being able to connect
them together
with um what we call cloud native which
is leveraging um functions written in
lambda
which is a
a javascript in java programming and
language actually you can write mandarin
in many languages but javascript and
java is the preference um um and uh
being able to uh really connect all the
services together and we what ended up
happening is that we had a team of um
three or four people um um the
environment uh itself as you can see uh
went from having uh
10 high-end servers to zero servers
because they're completely running in
the cloud there was no software to
deploy because we were building it all
in the cloud um and
the actual configuration and monitoring
and security all that was being managed
by aws
and we were able to turn around this
solution in under a month so it was it
took a third of the time to
develop with a third of the people and
so you start doing the math and it's
like wow this is just really a
phenomenal story um so
um
what i would say is as we look um and
start growing out your skills stop uh
start thinking about that when you move
to the cloud in 2022 um yes you're going
to go there for reasons such as
infinite compute power near infinite
computer uh near infinite storage i
think one of the things that um uh um
azure uh will say is that they have uh
oral intensive purposes infinite storage
that you can access um and the barrier
to entry is
is zero dollars um which is just
phenomenal stop thinking about um
the the move to cloud being just data
and compute power think of that as just
kind of the stepping stone that once you
actually get into the cloud now you can
take advantage of all the services that
are available there take advantage of
the new services that are coming out
that allow you to connect with your
existing legacy systems and extend
leverage the accelerators for instance
uh aws this week they have their ignite
conference and one of the accelerators
that they introduced is a visual ml
studio where you can actually build a
machine learning solutions uh quickly
and efficiently uh
similar in um uh to microsoft azure's ml
studio which again runs in the cloud so
you can actually build these systems
that are typically very complex systems
all in the cloud
so let's move on to the next screen
so
as you look into this space you know
what are the um you know the skills and
proficiencies that you need to be able
to
uh come up to speed with the the cloud
environment so i would argue that you
know first of all
being here and learning these skills
through simply learn is a phenomenal uh
first step um assembly line has done a
fantastic job of keeping up to speed on
uh the skill sets needed for devops and
cloud specific
but i'd also then look at a lot of the
skills that are out there a lot of the
technologies um uh there's not just the
the practice of
managing containers but also
leveraging um how do you build that
infrared
devops environment from the
container technology that you use to
kubernetes uh and the cloud technologies
around that um look at
what the cloud native service providers
um have
from aws gcp azure alibaba etc um
those are are always
um
it's always very important to keep up to
date with those skills um and what's
good is that there's a lot of um
services that you can go to out on the
internet that can make it very easy um
for you to be able to understand what
skills to look at so i've actually
provided a link to landscape
and this will provide you the cloud
native interactive landscape um but you
can go to the website um and it allows
you to filter through all the different
technologies out there um one of the
things that you have to consider when
you're building out uh an architecture
for um a solution and i run into this um
with a lot of clients today
um is that i i hear a lot of people
saying look i want to be
cloud agnostic or
i want to be able to move from cloud to
cloud
and that is certainly possible um a lot
of the tools that you can use are um
often open source um and it can it's
certainly a lot easier to be cloud open
agnostic um but uh one of the the the
challenges you have in that is that it
will inherently
provide a significant layer um a
significant amount of um architecture
that you have to build in um and i think
if you are certainly looking at your
first solution or
you're looking at having a solution that
is
either time restricted or you have a
limited number of people and we're all
running challenges with the number of
people that can actually work on
solutions
or you have um you know just a budget
restriction you may want to consider
going and building out your solution as
a native solution leveraging the
technologies that are available with
that cloud provider
so
um you know how can you
take your career and pivot rapidly
to the cloud
and there's a number of ways in which
this can be accomplished um
you know there are um you know i would
argue that you know yes you can go down
the path of getting a degree
um um the computer science um uh
certifications you can get now whether
it's an associate's degree a four-year
degree master's or a phd are much more
sophisticated than they were uh gosh
even
10 years ago
there are um i would say a fast uh path
uh to uh being able to um uh
create accreditation uh for your skill
set is to get certification um there's a
lot of cloud certifications that you can
go through
um
all of the cloud providers have
certification programs and they're very
extensive um i mean it it's with aws 10
years ago it was just one certificate
and now i don't know how many they have
i think it's like hundreds um um but i
would certainly uh
with i'm not sure if gcp has this but uh
with azure and with
uh aws i would i would definitely if you
haven't already done it do the
foundation certificate um it's it's a
hard it's actually a hard exam um to
pass um but what you'll come um have
coming out of it is a solid
understanding of all of the core
technologies uh that are
available within
those platforms and then
all of the vendors
actually have training programs
uh so depending on the
direction you want to go uh you can then
take and follow those
those training programs
in addition to that um all of the the
vendors there's constant content coming
out um
for instance uh simply learn we write a
lot of um articles that uh uh follow
technologies as well as providing uh
training
uh but you'll also
find that uh the leading companies at
aws azure and gcp they all have a lot of
fresh content coming out um myself
personally i love going on to youtube um
and uh watching videos and for instance
with ignite happening this week there's
a lot of training videos that are coming
out about new technologies and so i'll
go on to youtube and one of the
techniques that i have learned is um
when i'm watching a video uh you can
often go into the settings of the video
and i'll increase the playback speed
from uh
normal speed which they have as one i'll
actually increase it either to one and a
half or sometimes even double the speed
and to have it play back twice as fast
the reason why i do that
is um i want to get straight to
the the core of the the information and
if i need to um when when i'm actually
um
watching the the uh the content uh if i
need to slow down i can obviously slow
down in real time
uh but um i find that um i am more
focused on actually watching the content
and then actively learning and then the
the next thing once you've actually
learned the skill set is then to go to
the cloud provider and
uh often or not you'll find that
with a lot of the services
you can actually start um building out
solutions for free this isn't applied to
all the services but
certainly most of the services that i
have used
i'm able to go in and i can actually
start building out the uh the solutions
for free and just um it's something that
um you know it gets your skills up you
can prototype out a solution very
quickly um and again one of the things
that you want to focus on when you're
prototyping
particularly with new technology is
don't focus on building out the whole
solution but build out enough of the
solution
where you can effectively show
what can be done when you are to the
possible um and then
um that's when you can then get the
investment to be able to move forward
um
so those are those are the the kind of
the kickstarts you know take training
take certification but then practice by
doing um which is fully accessible to
all of us you just need to have a
computer to be able to get them um
then after that i would really focus on
building a portfolio um you know create
a brand about the work that you're doing
um you know look at giving back one of
the reasons why i write articles on
technology
particularly with the focus on devops
and cloud is i want people to know that
i'm an expert and the only way that uh
you can do that is by showing people so
build a portfolio of the work that
you've done
but then look at sites such as linkedin
and look at their blogging
features um
or you know look at their
uh
tools that allow you to do micro
blogging and just start posting content
you know start sharing information about
what you have learned and why you think
it was valuable um it doesn't have to be
long and complex but what you want to do
is establish yourself
as a
thought leader within that one given
space
and then what that does is that it
really has a two-fold effect one is you
are driving value through what you're
communicating
but the second is that people then are
becoming aware of you and as i mentioned
earlier on um the the market for
the the skill set you have right now is
just
incredibly um uh
hot
and so people want to know that you're
out there so you know start
communicating effectively out to them
all right so i think i mean that was
just kind of uh you know covering the
the content we have i think we're at the
point now for questions and answers um
i'm going to go off full screen here if
i can figure that out um and
um how do we want what is the most
effective way of doing the uh questions
and answers um so i've got uh the
questions queued up here and uh
coming in
throughout the session and
i'll uh ask you a few of these so that
uh
we have a good amount of time for them
um
we have
sandeep asks if you could actually i'm
going to give you back the sharing well
no i'll i'll do it from my side um
you wanted to ask a question about the
aws slide
back let me
um
that was slime
i've got it i will i will share it from
here
yep
um
and i do want to point out that this is
not a complete breakdown of all the
services um but this is a breakdown of
the most popular services okay
and
let's see if i can
see in
chat here if
cindy
so sandeep's question about this is how
many services are offered by aws
um so
that's a really good question because
every time i go to aws the number has
changed um and the number just keeps
getting bigger and bigger um so
what you'll find is aws
they have
their core primary services so we have
like networking compute services
security
um
app services mobile services those will
be the the primary and then there's a
second and then for each of the primary
uh services uh your click um and then
there'll be a uh so the primary category
and then there'll be services underneath
each of those um
categories
however there are additional services
beyond that
so i think that they will promote um
they promote like their top 150 200 uh
services but there's actually over 1800
services when i
last saw the official count and again
i'm sure that number has gone up
yeah i mean it just it's it proliferates
at an astounding rate
yes actually i can find i can pull in um
they have a they actually have a
catalog
which lists
all the services let me see if i can
find that
if you'd like to display it let me know
let me just i'll just i'll share the the
link
okay that's perfect um
put that in the chat
yeah put it in the right place
okay
yeah don't allow me to to chat but um i
i can
um
so you can actually just go to
aws.amazon.com uh service catalog um and
actually list
out all the services and it's just i
mean just a lot of them okay
uh
we have a question from centerian who in
the youtube uh
audience
um
it's a
one of those questions that is very
simple in form and very complex to
answer which is it's which is better
aws or azure
oh
gosh
i mean i think in general how do you
make the the kind of trade-off decisions
to choose which cloud platform is best
for your application
i i so there's a number of
things you need to take into
consideration um
uh you know uh
like i mentioned that i i like working
in azure um but i'm actually certified
in aws
um and
um and i and i really like both
platforms um the reason why i personally
prefer um azure is just you know my
background's microsoft engineer so
yeah you would gravitate to what we like
um but i would say both are very very
good
i mean i honestly both are like top of
the game
i would also argue that gcp and alibaba
are also equally as good um and um
i would also throw in um some of the the
the other solutions that we're seeing
from um like companies like
huawei uh the red hat acquisition that
ibm made a couple years ago really
really smart um so that there's
phenomenal growth so that's one part to
it though but the second part is as an
enterprise one things that you
invariably have to make is a decision on
who your partner is going to be and um
and when you look at enterprise scale of
going to the cloud it's not cheap it's
it's you know because we're looking at
taking the uh on-premise environment
which you're paying for today uh with
skilled people with uh with uh
servers and storage and a building and
you're moving it to the cloud so you
know you're gonna pay for that but um
you know if you're looking to make those
kind of changes um i would talk to all
of the the leading providers because um
invariably they'll provide financial
incentives for you to be able to move uh
to their environment so it's the second
thing um that you look at and then the
third is
understanding where is the what is the
direction that
that you your company or your skill set
where you want to go
um and
uh what do i mean by that is you know as
you look at you know one of the things i
always like to do is say look where do i
want to be
two years from now um and
for me personally
one of the areas that i really want to
be good at is um
what's happening with aiops i mean uh at
big um
right yeah so ai office department uh
with ai so for me ai and ai is an
umbrella term which you have automation
of systems with ai ops you also have
mlaps but then you also have uh
acceleration of um
rpa
and and ai and it's like how does the
whole ai umbrella technologies uh impact
my career in the future so uh for me
personally i look at it's like which
vendor do i want to follow um and i
would argue right now i feel that um
that google is probably the leader in
that space
um but it's not like they're like fur
longs ahead they've got other companies
and nipping at their at their toes as
well so yes easy question to ask hard
question to answer yeah
there's a similar uh one but i think you
you touched on it
which of the platforms is most cost
effective
so one of the things that
that
all of the platforms have been
announcing over the last year is that
their prices continue to go down and um
this just happened again this week with
ignite um uh
amazon is actually introdu uh building a
new generation of chipsets so so one of
the things that with with a lot of the
um vendors out there and and i'll throw
facebook in here as an example when
facebook were building out their cloud
environment they actually ended up
building their own chipsets for them for
their networks
because they're very specialized uh
needs
and uh and an aws is no different um if
you go into an aws um uh cloud
environment uh into one if you see any
of the videos all of the chips um all of
their system on chipsets that they have
are custom-made um and they just
introduce a new chipset which allows for
i think like 25 more energy efficiency
um and those kind of efficiencies
immediately get converted over to
pricing
so what you'll hear over and over again
from all of the vendors is that uh their
goal is to get cheaper and cheaper over
time only obviously again but we end up
spending more time using their services
but hey that's what what value's all
about isn't it
yeah um there are a number of questions
about careers before i get to those i
want to ask or i want to to pass on a
comment
from michael who
said
i think
that the no
dedicated infraops team is a
simplification
that assertion
wouldn't bear an enterprise migration to
an enterprise level hybrid model or an
entirely public hosted model
um
so is is that a an
accurate uh
no okay so so the solution we actually i
presented was an enterprise uh level
solution it was one that we
it was actually a product that we have
sold to many companies
um and then we uh we migrated
um
two and again i think one of the things
i wanted to to
stress is that we had built the the
first generation of it on modern
technologies
i think the the challenge we have and
i'm working with a couple of clients
right now is most of us already have
existing uh you know
use equals legacy systems and some of
them aren't as so legacy as we like to
think i mean we have solutions that
we're calling legacy systems which are
mobile apps built in
2015 um what we have to look at is
the opportunity moving forward is not to
move everything to the cloud
the opportunity is how can we get access
to all of our data
so the cloud is the the tool set
but the data is where our value is and
so this is why my focus over the next
couple years is on the umbrella of ai
tools because what i want to be able to
do
is be able to mine
that data be able to uh scale up the
access or being able to uh
work that data
through rpa and other technologies being
able to use aiops to get and manage and
secure the data scope at scale and so
how do we get to that so that from that
we can now start doing business rules
and sort of business analysis and really
kind of expose those opportunities so
that's where i see the tool set which is
you know partly cloud but also on-prem
and hybrid and other tools that's why i
see that becoming more
complex over the next few years
as we understand more about the value of
the data that we have
okay
um so let's get to some questions that
relate to career development um
richard zakia mutes asks
i'd love to venture further into clouds
and devops but i'm not a software
engineer is it feasible to do that
absolutely
just as a frame of reference
my degree is english literature and
communications
i do not have a engineering background
but
more recent my
my daughter uh her uh
fiance uh he um uh just recently came
out of
the military uh no
software engineering background and he's
been out for a year um and he has
self-taught himself how to um
build uh computers um and is now
migrating to the cloud i think what you
have to start with is a passion for
understanding what can be done um so
you clearly you're here you have that
passion um and
what you want to now start doing is two
things one is there's just uh so many
great youtube videos out there which is
um which will be starting you know and i
always look for the getting started or
how to start developing in you know
whatever technology start working with
those um
when i was experimenting i ran an iot
team
from 2012 to 2018
and to get myself up to speed um i would
sit and uh when
at the time aws had come out with um i
can't remember what the technology was
remember they have that button
technology where you can press the
button and reorder something um well you
can actually buy the button and actually
uh code to that um and so i wanted to
know how to do that so i watched a
youtube video um and i was able to then
a week later go in and run a
demonstration
uh to uh my client on how
somebody could reorder uh oil for their
car by just pressing a button that could
be included with uh the vehicle when it
was sold um and
and it was just
crazy easy to do because people have
already
set the path for you so don't be afraid
to um
don't be intimidated by
just the
what you need to learn because there's
just a lot to learn just get started and
and you'll be surprised how quickly uh
you'll pick things up
um want to note that i dropped into the
chat
a link to simply learn's resources page
where we have
a bunch of
free content articles videos tutorials
ebooks
a lot on the topics of you know how to
get started or
how to perform a particular task
um
so yeah that a lot of is out there um
i think you've addressed emanuel's
question which was what advice you'd
have for people who don't have a first
degree
in computer science because you just
described that situation for
yourself and your
future son-in-law and a couple of other
people so
um
what about somebody who is
a software engineer what is
the
um
best path for the software developer
software engineer
to move into cloud computing or devops
so that's a really good question um and
what we're looking at is you know how do
you take your current skills and then
skill up to a new environment and and
and this is something that again i work
with a lot of um clients about how do we
skill up uh your existing workforce so
that they can be embracing these you
know uh quote-unquote modern
technologies um i i think you know
really first of all the first thing you
want to do is take the foundation
certificate from either aws or azure or
google it um i i would say probably aws
or azure to begin with um that's just a
great start because it'll give you an
understanding of
the
umbrellas um
set of technologies out there but then
the second is sign up uh sign up with
any of the the leading cloud vendors
all of them have
free accounts but you can use
where you can get in and you can
actually start playing around with
the technologies this is something you
can do in your own time you don't have
to
um you know spend a lot of money on uh
software or services it's all running in
the cloud so you can do it right from
your
laptop
um so that'd be the second thing and the
third is um you know find out um you
know patient like like simply learn
where the you know the the the cost of
taking the classes is incredibly low and
the value you get out of them is just
incredibly high um and it'll help you um
you know kind of
jump your skill set forward very quickly
okay
um
we have a couple of questions specific
to
personal situations
so floyd asks is manufacturing engineer
would like to get into i.t and data
science
and devops and cloud are very
interesting
um
if you're looking at data science versus
devops versus cloud versus maybe aiml
what field would be the easiest to
transition into or the best place for
him to to start
i i would say so so for me cloud and
devops kind of go hand in hand um so i
would look at um i would look at going
to the cloud because you have the
practical ability to
learn uh
tools but then your workflow which is
devops um i would learn that at the same
time and then and you'll see that it
kind of gets forced on you because uh
you have pipelines you have to manage
well you're you're moving your content
and how you um move your solution
delivery through the um through the
environment so that would be the the
first place um but then in parallel to
that it is ai and ai again is a it's a
very large
environment but the the barrier to entry
to ai uh keeps coming down i mean uh two
years ago
i would have said you know get started
with python um i think i i wrote for you
stuart and an article on
uh the the tools and how to how to learn
python in a hundred days or something i
can't i seem to remember writing
something like that for you yeah
um you know but but you can it's in the
resources section yes okay
so so you can you can learn how to um
become an expert with like tools like
python uh for free i mean you don't have
to i um you know you know spend a lot of
money on this um the investment you're
gonna make is on your time um so i would
i would put together a plan um and you
know this is just you know how i work
and um but um when i'm uh uh providing
coaching to to my teams is um i'm i'm
you know from from personal development
i would say look um don't look at where
you want to be
uh two years from now um two years is
your goal that's you know that's i want
to be seen as xyz kind of expert but if
you're looking to have tangible benefit
look at what you need to accomplish in
the next 90 days
and maybe even the next 30 days and the
reason why i say that is we all have
lives and
we have kids
or we have uh partners or we have
friends and family yeah there's lots of
influences in our lives and so it's very
hard to be able to make very big uh
plans um to hit specific goals um over a
two year period but it's very easy to
make very small plans such as um
i
i i want to sign up and
um
and
use my um one service in aws um using
their their free sign up tool i want to
do that and i want to accomplish that in
the next seven days well you know you're
talking about an hour of your time so
you can do that you can put those kind
of things together so
that's that's what i encourage you to do
is is is have a vision of where you want
to go but then put together a plan that
may be a 30-day plan a 90-day plan of
how you're going to get there um and be
realistic and you know some of the the
the
some you there are some videos out there
where um um there's uh one that i saw
where uh it was you know how to become
an expert in you know 100 days on
something but it was it was very
unrealistic about the the time coming
you were looking at like four or five
hours a day for a hundred days and said
well none of us have four or five hours
a day because you know we have jobs um
so you know um that's
yeah but but you you can do that um but
um just being meaningful and how you
approach it yeah
that makes sense and and you know as
you're saying time commitment for
example you know
simply learns programs even the most
advanced ones
generally have a time commitment that's
just five to ten hours a week
yeah mostly you know basically taking
your saturday and devoting it to
your training
exactly
exactly and
i wanted to to that point one of the
things that i have done is and and this
is just something that that i am i'm
kind of an early riser so i'm normally
up at 5 30 or 6 in the morning and
and i still get up early on the weekend
and so i end up having typically uh
three or four hours on a saturday
morning on a sunday morning
where the rest of my family aren't up
and so i use that time uh to learn
something new and and i and i i'm very
creative i you know sometimes it is
uh learning about a new technology
sometimes yeah i'm into 3d printing at
the moment so i i was learning about 3d
printing a couple weeks ago so you know
those that that's my learning time that
i give to myself
yeah
um
looking at another question from
richards
so he recently passed the ad aws clf01
exam congratulations and he would like
to know you know
if he's looking to get a role in cloud
computing what are the what would be a
good next step for him
uh it really depends on where your
interests are are you going to go down
the networking path are you going to go
down
the development path
i i would i would look at where you want
to go right now you have
a good certificate i'm delighted that
you've taken that um but you now have to
start looking at specializing um and and
the reason why i bring that up
is that um the market as i mentioned a
couple of times it's white hot right now
for skills um and but you are more
likely to increase the amount of
compensation that you're gonna get
by specializing in a certain area um and
i would say right now security is
probably
proper gosh you know
there is getting people that have
security expertise is just almost
impossible um so if you want to almost
guarantee yourself getting a job and
getting certified with going down the
security path would be a really good
path to go
but honestly all of them are all really
good and just having the certifications
um
and then making sure that those
certifications are clearly visible uh in
your resume when you're applying for
roles
will help you differentiate you from
other people that are applying for those
roles
danish
asks
he's a
tech support engineer i would like to
know if devops is the best
path to switch into
uh so i have um i have a bias here so
i have to be cautious on how i answer
this is that um
i have been leading uh devops teams or
teams um long before it was known as
devops um like almost 20 years now
and and that's simply because of the
technologies that um uh i have uh
gravitated towards
uh
typically that there are
um
typically there are three ways of
delivering solutions um there is you
know traditional waterfall
and then you have agile and then you
have devops and
what i find is
agile becomes
the ability to do devops um
a lot of companies though are still
struggling moving away from traditional
waterfall i mean you know we talk about
delivery of project planning that goes
back decades and decades back to you
know the 1930s and 1940s um
but the the reality is in in a cloud
world um
it simply doesn't work and i'm and i'm
working with a couple of clients right
now um that um are embracing the cloud
and are running into the cultural
challenge um of what cloud you know the
opportunity cloud offers and and we're
making the the wise pivot of uh
embracing devops uh so i have a passion
around devops um i i think it's i i
don't think there's any project that can
cannot be done with devops people will
tell me differently but
i i found that you can use it for even
just you know complex environments like
you know traditional like sap ecc you
can you can still apply devops uh
to that environment it's it's not easy
but it can be
done okay
thank you for that um
we have a couple quick questions one is
shikhar
asks
if you're only qualified in cloud
computing technology if that's your your
core
training certification
um
are there jobs available in that respect
or do you need to know other
technologies as well
so
you know it's a
first of all fantastic question uh are
there jobs yes there are there are a lot
of jobs um the reality is when you look
at cloud fundamentally a lot of the
stuff that we do in cloud isn't
different to what we were doing before
um and um you know we when we were on
pram um particularly with uh with
computer i mean it's just it's it's
almost identical but we have somebody
else managing it in the cloud
and
so
you don't have to become specialized in
another area um
i would i would argue that
if you are
good in cloud
what you're presenting yourself to to a
prospective clam
as a
suppressive employee
is that you've already taken the
initiative to
learn about
leading edge technology and and to be
clear cloud isn't cutting edge anymore
it hasn't been for a number of years
it's leading edge and the difference
there is that it means that most
companies are looking to embrace and
leverage cloud
and i would argue that the vast majority
of companies today are using cloud some
of them aren't aware that they're using
cloud um but they are using cloud and
you look at them for instance microsoft
office 365
most customers now run through the cloud
um cloud version of that
um and you have uh you know companies
like sap
moving rapidly to the cloud adobe has
been on the cloud for almost a decade
so this is the thing you have to bear in
mind when you look at all these
technologies and the companies driving
those technologies are cloud first
companies and so having that skill set
you're just opening yourself up for the
new market and the new market is very
hot
um
we have a
user from our youtube
stream who
says they're studying devops from an
academy um
are there going to be entry-level devops
jobs for people who have no
work experience prior work experience um
oh that's always a challenge and and
you know and it's one of the things that
i find frustrating because i remember uh
trying to get a job and
uh and having no experience and just how
difficult that is um
you know i i what i would do
uh to help compensate for that
is i would um
while you're
while you're actively sending out your
resume and and applying for jobs has
never been easier i would do two things
one
is i
contribute to your open source programs
um so you can actually put that in as
experience that you've been contributing
to an open source program
and pick something that is is well known
such as like kubernetes so that people
can actually see um you will recognize
it um and the second is i would look at
um
uh just kind of the crowd sourcing uh
platforms are out there and start
applying for position for roles that
those roles typically are very short in
duration um but the benefit you get from
them is while the pay isn't great a
you'll get paid um but b you'll get that
also that tangible experience so so both
of those will give you experience and
help fill out your resume
great answer um i'd also like to point
out the you know postgraduate programs
from simply learn
are all designed with a capstone project
that
you know simulates work experience and
helps you build up your your portfolio
so that
it helps you get to that level um
just like a couple more questions
because i see that we're running out of
time but um
and and we have many more questions that
have been submitted but i apologize to
the audience members that we can't
handle uh all of them in the time
available do you have one question
amman had asked what are the various
models available for cloud deployment
oh gosh
um so i would i would actually go to
those lots um and
a friend of mine actually
actually manages the communication for
cloud deployment models for uh for asha
uh so uh i would argue right now that
for the patent i would what i would do
is i would do a just a google search on
patterns of praxis and then pick a
specific cloud so azure and have their
own patents and practices um uh aws have
theirs as well um but there's there's a
lot out there um i was gonna try maybe i
could well
maybe we can do this
but um there are a lot in fact i might
and again stuart i believe i wrote an
article on patents and practices for uh
for azure and aws um so that's another
uh article that you can find in our
resources
that you can leverage and speaking of
resources fabrizio had asked about the
best
channels tools books resources to be you
know updated regarding cloud trends
and the ones that are most valuable for
developing a career and then
so before you answer that i'm going to
just plug the resources section of our
website again for example learn it's in
links in the in the chat um if you
scroll back you'll you'll see where i've
posted it but what are some of i mean
you've already talked about in the
presentation number of these
things on the career pivot slide
um is there anything you want to add
uh so a couple of things i would do is
make sure that you
subscribe to the aws azure gcp blogs
they are
just a great
source of material
i would find leaders on linkedin that
post regularly
about technology
and not just about themselves and what
they're selling um i i
uh so for myself personally i i very
rarely talk about uh myself on linkedin
but i'm always constantly posting about
stuff that i'm finding of value that i
like to share
so i would find some people who are
doing that
um and then i'd also get involved with
uh with groups and find out you know you
know is there a meet up uh nearby that
you can join it's always fantastic to um
connect with people uh even in our
virtual worlds that we're working in
today but the meetups are still
happening but they're happening
virtually rather than physically
so you know connect with like-minded
people ask ask them questions
great
um so i think that takes us to the end
of the webinar i have one more
poll i'd like to ask of the audience
and uh
this is
so that you were interested in matthew
and hearing what
their
views were on this
what are the skills you're most
interested in learning
and
given that you're interested in those
when would you like to start learning
them
so
uh have a
poll widget if you're watching live on
webex you can put comments into the live
stream channels
otherwise
and
about 15 more seconds so you have time
to
continue
and we did have a comment in the
questions
we'll probably want to do another
session matthew uh
sooner than later a
similar session but focusing more on
devops
a lot of uh interest in that area so
here are the poll results
and
as you can see most people are
interested in
aws and azure google cloud and then
devops not far behind
um and
about a third of the people responding
said they'd like to start right away
which is always a good plan and she said
it's uh easier to make a commitment to
do something in the
the here and now than to say well i'll
do it someday
so
um
i just want to say thank you to matthew
and to everybody for being here uh
i will put his linkedin
um
link into
the chat for you
um
but matthew thank you so much
thank you i thank you so much for
inviting me stuart it's always a
pleasure catching up with you and i
really appreciate everybody joining i
saw at one point we had over 200 uh
people here just on the uh
the webex session i can't imagine
outside of that as well and it just the
commitment that everybody's making to
learn about this uh just as a reflection
on the type of person you are and the
direction that you can take your career
thank you so much um
what i will do also is we send out a
follow-up email to our audience
um with a link to the webinar recording
and
some people have asked to get
a pdf of the slide decks for so they can
look in more detail at the some of the
more dense
information so i will
include that
and um
i'll just also mention that we've
talked about certifications
we have a number of courses and programs
that simply learn these are essentially
the
top of the pyramid
which are
nine month
or so programs
include in collaboration with caltech
which is one of the world's
leading universities
um
and home of a number of nobel prize
winners
and these programs
are very comprehensive and in that
capstone that i mentioned where you do a
uh
industry
type problem
and
provide a solution that you can then you
know show off to potential employers
i will also mention that if you go to
these
pages you can also browse through the
website and find other courses and
programs
so you have a lot of options and
with that i'm just going to
we'll skip over that because that's a
past
event
this
concludes the webinar keep in touch with
us please
at simply learn at facebook
twitter
simply learn on linkedin
and
we look forward to having you at future
webinars
and we also look forward to having you
join our learner community
so again thank you to matthew thank you
to all of you for being here
and
we'll see you soon
thanks david thanks everybody
you